The longest Star Wars movie so far, The Last
Jedi is densely packed with tons of details
and easter eggs that even some die-hard fans
may have missed on a first viewing.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and today I want to talk about some fascinating
references and hidden details in Episode 8
that have more significance than you might
have initially realised.
And if you're new to my channel, I do regular
easter egg videos, movie breakdowns, theories
and deleted scenes, plus giveaways.
To enter my current Star Wars giveaway, just
make sure you're subscribed and leave me a
comment about any easter eggs or interesting
details you spotted in the film.
Spoiler warning, I'll be discussing scenes
from The Last Jedi in depth so take care if
you haven't seen the movie yet.
After Yoda returned as a Force Ghost, reuniting
with Luke on Acht'To, the legendary Jedi Master
burned down the island's ancient Force Tree.
And when Luke protested about the destruction
of the sacred Jedi texts and Yoda replied
that there was nothing in there "that the
girl Rey does not already possess", it seemed
that the ancient books had burned with the
Tree, but that Rey had already mastered everything
in them.
However, Yoda's words actually had another
meaning which became clear at the end of the
movie.
There's a crucial moment on the Millennium
Falcon when Finn opens a drawer to get a blanket
to cover the injured Rose Tico, and as Finn
rummages around, you can spot the Jedi books
right there, meaning that Rey actually took
them from the island.
So, Yoda's reply to Luke was a clever bit
of wordplay and suggests that Rey has more
to learn.
Of course, it also means that Rey and the
Resistance still have the old Jedi scripts
which they can use to inspire and teach new
Force Users about the Jedi way.
Near the start of the film, Rey tells Luke
that the Resistance needs his help to face
their enemies, and he replies, "You think,
what?
I'm gonna walk out with a laser sword and
face down the whole First Order?"
Luke's use of the word "laser sword" is an
easter egg to George Lucas's early Star Wars
scripts where that term was used instead of
lightsaber; and in The Phantom Menace, we
hear the same term used by a young Anakin
Skywalker.
As well as containing a hat tip to the saga's
origins, Luke's reply to Rey also foreshadows
the end of the movie.
In contrast to what he said, Luke does indeed
walk out armed with just a lightsaber and
confront the entire First Order.
And yet, Luke also stays true to his original
words to Rey, because it's not actually his
physical self who faces down the First Order,
but rather a Force Projection.
Ahch-To is home to the first Jedi temple which
has a curious ancient mosaic on its floor
of the Prime Jedi, the very first member of
the Jedi Order.
The mosaic's design is reminiscent of a yin-yang
symbol and shows the Prime Jedi "in a state
of meditation and balance", which foreshadows
Luke's own position on the island at the end
of the movie.
The image also shows a fusion of light and
dark, which is interesting because in The
Last Jedi, Rey and Kylo Ren form a force bond
between them and Kylo asks Rey to join him.
Of course, the mosaic also symbolises the
tension that Force Users experience of being
pulled between the light and the dark sides.
For example, Kylo struggles with his connection
to the dark side and experiences a "pull to
the light", as he calls it.
There's a clear parallel between the hole
that Rey climbs into on the Jedi Temple island
and the Dark Side cave that Luke entered during
his training on Dagobah.
Both the caves force the entrant to confront
their worst fear.
For Luke, this appeared to be the evil that
Darth Vader represented, but when the cave
exposed Luke's face inside Vader's helmet,
it showed that Luke's real fear was that he
might turn to the Dark side, and it also foreshadowed
the reveal that he was Darth Vader's son.
Although we don't hear the reveal of Rey's
parents until later in The Last Jedi, we do
get an interesting bit of foreshadowing via
Rey's experience in the cave.
Rey's always been waiting for her parents
to return to her, but when she sees her own
image endlessly reflected back to her, it
foreshadows the discovery later that she's
actually known the answer within herself all
along, in other words she is alone.
Or as Maz Kanata said in The Force Awakens,
'whomever you're waiting for [...], they're
never coming back.'
In a call-back to the time Luke crash-landed
in a swamp on Dagobah in The Empire Strikes
Back, there's a submerged X-wing on the shores
of the Jedi Temple island.
And Luke has salvaged an S-foil from that
underwater X-wing to make a door for his stone
hut on Ahch'To.
In The Last Jedi, we get to meet Snoke close
up and although we still don't know his backstory,
there's one item he owns which reveals some
secrets about his connection to the Dark Side.
The gold ring the Supreme Leader wears on
his finger is etched with symbols of the Four
Sages of Dwartii.
The Four Sages were philosophers from the
planet Dwartii who, in the early days of the
Republic, stirred controversy, promoted the
study of the Dark Side of the Force, and were
popular among the Sith.
In fact, Palpatine had statues of them in
his office in Attack of the Clones.
Snoke also has a link to another legendary
Sith Lord, as the black stone in the ring
is actually obsidian mined from the catacombs
below Darth Vader's Castle on the volcanic
planet Mustafar, which was also the location
of Anakin and Obi-Wan's fateful duel in Revenge
of the Sith.
The way Poe Dameron toys with General Hux
at the start of the film, pretending he can't
hear him and is waiting to be patched through
by Hux's communications officer, is reminiscent
of the start of The Force Awakens where Poe
made fun of Kylo Ren after being captured,
asking who should talk first and saying it
was hard to understand him through the mask.
And in The Last Jedi, Poe's line, "Tell [Hux]
Leia has an urgent message for him... about
his mother" is a dig at the fact that Hux
is an illegitimate child whose mother was
a kitchen worker, a fact which was revealed
in a recent canon Star Wars novel.
Speaking of Poe, after he struck up a bromance
with ex-stormtrooper Finn in The Force Awakens,
it was nice to see them reunite when Finn
woke up in his Bacta suit.
And after Finn got dressed, he donned Poe's
old jacket which, if you look carefully, you
can see has been repaired after Finn's run-in
with Kylo Ren in Episode 7.
In fact, it was Poe who stitched the jacket
back up while Finn was recovering, a detail
I'm sure fans of Stormpilot will particularly
like.
BB-8 got to do some pretty cool things in
The Last Jedi and, while on board the Supremacy,
Finn disguised him with a black metal can
making him resemble a rather large mouse droid.
He even scoots along making noises that are
uncannily similar and match the pattern made
by an MSE-6 repair droid in A New Hope.
To top it all, BB-8 also bumps into a Stormtrooper
on the Supremacy, just like the mouse droid
ran into Han and Luke disguised as Stormtroopers
alongside Chewie in Episode 4.
After Leia recovers from her time in space,
there's a nice call back to one of her first
scenes in A New Hope.
When she bursts through the door to confront
the mutinous Poe Dameron, she's dressed in
white like we saw her in Episode 4 and she
uses her blaster in stun mode on Poe, sending
out blue circular blasts, just how the Stormtroopers
blasted Leia to catch her at the beginning
of A New Hope.
Leia's scenes in The Last Jedi have, of course,
taken on an added poignancy since Carrie Fisher
passed away.
And although it's unclear what exactly will
happen with Leia in Episode 9, Episode 8 was
a real Fisher family affair, with both her
daughter Billie Lourd playing Lieutenant Connix
again, and the additional bonus of a space
cameo by Carrie's dog Gary.
Look out for him on Canto Bight in the casino
scene where an alien dog appears whose design
was based on the much-loved actress's famous
pet.
During the battle on Crait, the Millennium
Falcon loses its radar dish again.
As Chewie tries to outmanoeuvre some TIE fighters,
the ship gets caught in a tight spot in some
underground caves and one of the TIE fighters
gets a shot on the sensor dish, blasting it
off.
The original circular sensor dish was lost
when Lando flew the Falcon in Return of the
Jedi.
The astonishing ending to The Last Jedi also
has some important easter eggs and call-backs
from binary sunsets on Tatooine, to Sith force
projections, and Luke becoming one with the
Force.
I go into detail on these and more in my Last
Jedi ending explained video as well as talking
theories on Episode 9.
If you haven't seen that, just tap in the
top right to watch or click the link in the
video description.
Now, did you spot any cool details or easter
eggs in the movie?
And what were your favourite moments?
Leave me a comment below and make sure you
subscribe to enter my Star Wars giveaway for
an awesome Last Jedi Funko Pop.
I've got more Last Jedi videos on the way,
so turn on notifications to keep up-to-date,
and in the meantime, check out more of my
videos you're sure to like here!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee ki-yay, movie lovers!